NADN has been one of the most powerful
noode tools on the market for some time
now. But today, as platforms like Claude
Code, Codeex, and anti-gravity become
both more powerful and more
userfriendly, one of the skills you need
to master is taking your NADN
automations, agents, and workflows and
being able to convert them into proper
applications when called for. Now this
is something we have touched on in
previous videos where we have taken any
automations and used cloud code to
essentially build a wrapper around them.
We've given them a front end, a backend,
databases, the works. But at its core,
it was still an NAN JSON file
essentially powering all the logic. But
in today's video, we're taking it a step
further. We aren't creating a wrapper
this time because instead we're going to
be taking an NAND JSON file and turning
it into a proper Python app. And for
today's demo, we are going to be
converting one of my favorite NAND
workflows. It's a Rag AI agent powered
by LightRag. But this video isn't about
any one-off project. What this video is
really about is giving you a framework
to convert any NAND automation you want
while also having a nuance discussion
about when this sort of conversion when
this transformation from NAN to real
code actually makes sense and when it
doesn't and what the pros and cons
really are. So with that let's get to
it. So let's take a look at the AI agent
we are going to be converting today.
This is a RAG AI agent. Rag stands for
retrieval augmented generation and
essentially that means our AI agent is
hooked up to a vector database in this
case a graph rag system using light rag
which allows it to take on a bunch of
documentation and then answer questions
about it right that's essentially all
that means and there's three parts to
this AI agent you have the AI agent
system right here which allows you to
actually query and ask questions second
you have a data pipeline so we need some
way to actually ingest docu douments
into the system. Right? If I want to ask
this AI agent questions about meeting
notes, well, how do I get the meeting
notes into the vector database? That's
what this does. And then third, we need
some sort of data cleanup system, right?
So imagine I uploaded meeting notes into
the database. Well, what happens if I
delete it from the database? Maybe I put
in the wrong thing. Does that get
deleted in the vector database? Right?
You need some sort of data syncing
system. So all of that exists here
inside of N&NN and it works well, but
it's three disperate systems and it's in
one JSON file and we essentially want to
push it into real code using cloud code
for three reasons. And these three
reasons don't just apply to this light
rag AI agent in a vacuum. This sort of
applies in general as well. And the
three big reasons and these aren't
exhaustive is performance, cost, and
control. First of all, let's talk about
performance. Right now, this rag agent
lives inside of NAND. That's either
going to be on the NAND cloud or if
you're self-hosted on whatever cloud you
host NADN on. But the light rag system
itself, due to the way NAN is set up,
cannot live inside of NAND, it's going
to have to be on its own server
somewhere else. And that comes at a
performance cost. Every time I talk to
this AI agent here inside of NADN,
right? It now has to take the trip over
to the graph rag server. Figure out your
answer and bring it back. That costs us
time. That also moving on to point two
cost us money, right? I'm now dealing
with servers for NN. I'm now dealing
with servers for light rag. I'm now now
dealing with the cost associated with
running both of those and having both
talk to one another. Now compare that to
when we can have it operate as an actual
Python application. Light rag itself is
actually a Python library which means I
can create all of this everything we see
here in NAN using Python code and have
the graph rag interface database that
whole system just be a part of that code
essentially meaning all of it is in one
place right that reduces my cost that
increases performance everything is in a
nice neat little box and before you say
hey Chase couldn't we just do like a
code node here or something and do
Python and add libraries into all this
stuff. Well, then the question becomes,
why are we actually inside of NAND if
we're just scaffolding a bunch of code
notes together? And then that brings us
into point three, which is control. And
this is rather obvious. When I'm working
inside of NAND, I am constrained by the
platform itself, both in terms of its
tools and sort of legality issues,
right? Think about the naden fair use
policy and where that can constrain you.
Especially if you're trying to create
something like a SAS application where
you want to get paid for it versus if I
create this as a Python application by
myself with my code, I own it all,
right? I don't even have to think about
that. So I also have the entire breadth
and width of every coding tool
imaginable at my disposal, right? And I
h and I can access those things in a
less hacky way than creating something
inside of any where it's a bunch of code
nodes slapped together. Now, this is not
to say NIDN does not have its place. And
at the end of this video, we're going to
dive into that and I'm really going to
talk about, hey, here's where NAD does
make sense because it does still play a
part in your 2026 AI stack. But
understand, there are some major
advantages to moving away from NADN into
whatever you want to call it, real code
or whatever using something like log
code. So, now that you understand what
we're converting and why we're doing it,
now let's go through the how. And the
great part about this is it's actually
pretty easy. We are going to hop into
Claude Code. We are going to create a
new project folder. And I'm just going
to dump the JSON file that I downloaded
from NADN into the project folder. I'm
then going to go into plan mode. And
alls I'm going to do is I'm going to
say, hey, I put in this NADN automation
into the project folder. I want to
convert it into a real application. I
want to get outside of the JSON
structure. What do we need to do for
this? That's pretty much it. That's
pretty much all you have to do for
almost everything. No matter what
automation agent workflow you're doing,
that's what you got to do. Now, if you
have a well-created JSON file like mine,
and maybe you have some stuff written
over here about how it works, this will
go very, very smoothly. Right? If what
you're trying to convert inside of NAND
already works, well, guess what? The
JSON file is telling Claude Code what
it's supposed to do. It's just rewriting
that in essentially a different way
using Python or whatever it happens to
use. Now, obviously, there's 10 billion
different iterations of Naden workflows.
So, your use case will vary, but by and
large, it's really as simple as dropping
the template inside and then having a
conversation plan mode with cloud code
just explaining here's what I want to do
by the way, here's how it works and also
tacking on any differences you want to
make. All I wrote here was I want to
convert this NAD JSON rag agent into a
proper app. Take a look at the file.
It's in the folder and tell me what you
think. it's going to go to work. And
again, we're set up so well in this
scenario versus like creating some sort
of application from thin air using cloud
code. We've already done all the hard
work inside of NAND, right? You really
have. Now, as this is spinning up, let's
talk about though some of the roadblocks
that you will probably face and they're
going to be related to authentication
because inside of NAND, you've probably
already gone through the painstaking
authentication process inside of things
like Google, for example. We all know
how fun it is to get the Google Cloud
spun up. You're essentially going to
have to redo that, but this time inside
of Cloud Code, and sometimes the
processes are a little bit different,
but credentials by and large are the
biggest pain in the butt I have found
doing this. Again, luckily, Claude Code
will walk you through that process step
by step. And just like inside of Naden,
once you've gone through the
authentication process inside of Cloud
Code, that code is there. It's been
written. You can always reuse it. So,
Claude Code's now asking me some
questions about what we want that
conversion to look like. So, hey, I want
it to be a full web app. Asking me my
text stack. We can do Python. It's
asking me, do I want to keep the Google
Drive integration? Yes, keep the Google
Drive. And submit answers. And from
here, you just let it go to work. So,
after a few minutes, it creates all the
code for us. And then it comes back with
a checklist we need to complete on our
end to get this thing up and running.
So, first is the Google Cloud Service
account. So, again, Google Cloud kind of
a pain in the butt, but it makes it
pretty easy cuz it gives us the exact
steps to complete. Then we need to add
our open AI key, install the Python
packages in a separate terminal, test it
locally, push the GitHub, and then it
even shows us how to deploy it on
Railway. So, I'm going to run through
all that very quickly offscreen so you
don't have to watch me inside of Google
Cloud for 20 minutes, and we'll just go
ahead and take a look at the final
product. So, here's a look at our final
product for our graph rag system. What
we see right now is the front end of the
system. And in the back end, we're no
longer relying on an edit JSON file. We
have the full Python architecture that
was built by Cloud Code itself. And so
I'll test it out by asking it a
question. And we can see it comes back
with a pretty lengthy response where it
actually shows us where it's pulling all
of its information from. Essentially
citing all the sources that are inside
of its database. Pretty cool. And if you
want to learn more about Graphra and
especially Lightrag cuz it's a really
cool open source system, make sure you
check the description cuz I'll put a
link there. So now you see how simple it
is to make the conversion from these
naden workflows into real applications.
And now you're probably asking, well, if
it's this simple and I get all these
benefits, why even bother with naden in
the first place? And I think there's
some good reasons to still make sure you
have naden in your back pocket. And the
primary reason is its efficiency as a
prototyping and MVP tool. And the fact
that we can do this all visually is a
huge boon, especially if you're someone
who's rather new to this thing, aren't
very technical, or you're working with a
group or client who also isn't technical
and doing everything inside of the cloud
code infrastructure is a bridge too far.
Now, I may be pretty biased in this
regard, but I think the visual nature of
NADN really helps bring the point home
when you're trying to figure out how
data needs to flow through a system. And
that data visualization piece when it
comes to the architecture of an app, I
think it's super important because
understanding how data works and how it
flows from point A to point B, I think
is one of the fundamental skills you
must master in AI development and it's
one that's really hard to wrap your head
around if you aren't quote unquote
technical. On top of that, once you do
get the hang of NAN, being able to
create something like this is very, very
quick and you can customize it very
quickly. There's no back and forth with
claude of making sure, hey, did you
actually understand what I'm saying? If
you're someone who's more price
constrained, you're not worrying about
burning through tokens. And on top of
that, it's easy to get very, very
granular, right, in terms of each and
every node and really get your hands
dirty and understand, hey, like what's
going on here and what do I need to
change or fix to get the output I'm
looking for? And in the process of
getting hands-on with these automations,
when you're in the prototype phase and
you're trying to feel out what you're
even trying to build, I think it gets
you very intimate with the essential
coding logic of your application, which
in the long run, I think gives you much
better outcomes. So that's ultimately
where I think Naden shines in the big
picture. There's also the more obvious
things like, hey, if I'm doing a very
simple automation and I'm using a
nontechnical team, like hey, that's
something they can do as well. But I
think for a lot of people as they become
more mature in their AI development
journey, they tend to shy away from NAND
and move to clawed code and that's with
good reason. But I think there is still
a lot of value to extract from NAND even
as you become more comfortable with
these egentic coding agents. So that is
where I'm going to leave you guys today.
I hope if nothing else this showed you
how not scary it is to jump into claw
code if you're already comfortable with
NAN. really not a huge leap. Like you're
already there and you've done a lot of
the work upfront already. Now, I also
have a ton of resources if you want to
learn more about AI down in the
comments. I have the free school. All
the stuff in there is free. I also have
the paid Chase AI plus community. That's
if you're someone who is a little more
advanced in your AI journey and you're
trying to figure out, hey, how exactly
can I make money with this thing? So,
make sure you check both of those out. I
will also have the template you saw here
inside of the school community. So, let
me know what you thought of this video.